tonight is Game seven of the World
Series here in Los Angeles it's one of
the most exciting in recent memory
tonight's game is one of the hottest
tickets on the planet oh you're not
kidding I'm a huge Dodger fan and this
ticket cost me a fortune okay I'm
confused you have a ticket for Game
seven what are you doing here
well like I said I'm a huge Dodger fan
but I'm an even bigger Conan fan look at
me wrong I appreciate that but it's Game
seven of the World Series and this is
show three thousand nine hundred and
sixty seven of the best show on TV am i
right
it's my telling you that makes no sense
sorry as much as I love baseball I would
rather eat the four grand this ticket
cost me then miss one I'll see you
tomorrow Conan
hey what about tonight's I got it
covered don't worry about it
[Applause]
I know we have a terrific show tonight
from the NBC series the good place and
the new movie a bad mom's Christmas
Kristen Bell is here oh she's great
start the new movie wheelman frank
grillo is on the show o East fantastic
we're very close Fred's and comedian
Beth Stelling is on the show yes she is
a stand-up comedian
[Applause]
one more show coming up we'll be right
back Jimmy take it away
you